Últimamente hemos dedicado en VisualPolitik
varios vídeos a desgranar compromisos y
promesas de Donald Trump. Es normal,
al fin y al cabo, a partir del 20 de
enero de 2017 Trump es ya Presidente
de Estados Unidos.
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a tratar de
analizar algunas de sus apuestas en
seguridad nacional,
en concreto aquellas referentes a la
estrategia nuclear.
Y lo hacemos porque en diciembre de
2016 saltó el escándalo cuando
Trump la anunció ¡vía twitter! Tal cual,
amigos. Para saber qué se le pasa a Trump
por la cabeza
basta con estar atentos, por muy
increíble que parezca, a su cuenta de
twitter. Prácticamente, podemos decir que
twitter es a Trump lo que la M60 es a
Rambo o la Colt 45 a Billy el Niño.
A través de esta red
lo mismo le aconseja a Israel pasar de
Obama y de la ONU, que tacha de ser un
tipo sin talento al mismísimo editor de
la revista Vanity Fair.
No importa lo que ocurra, si Donald se
levanta enfadando, se le atraganta el
desayuno o de repente quiere cambiar la
política mundial, nos enteraremos
siempre por twitter. Y no os penséis que
lo hace de una forma serena,
de hecho, en el tramo final de la
campaña electoral sus asesores le
quitaron literalmente la cuenta. Pero... no
nos desviemos. El pasado 22 de diciembre
de 2016,
Trump anuncio lo siguiente en twitter y
se armó la marimorena:
-  "El presidente electo Donald Trump reaccionó por twitter y
dijo que Estados Unidos debe fortalecer
y ampliar su capacidad nuclear hasta que
el mundo entra en razón sobre las
consecuencias de usar armas nucleares".
Pero ¿esto qué significa?
Porque si lo que quiere decir es que
Trump apuesta por actualizar y poner al
día las capacidades nucleares de
Estados Unidos, pues tampoco parece que
haya noticia ¿verdad?
De hecho, esto es lo que se apresuró a
decir su equipo de prensa para explicar este tweet.
- " Su equipo declaró, después,
que se refería a modernizar el arsenal
no ampliarlo".
Al fin y al cabo casi nadie cuestiona
que el concepto de "destrucción mutua
asegurada" que surgió con las armas
nucleares fue una garantía de paz
durante la guerra fría e impidió a las
grandes potencias hacer lo que habían
hecho siempre: pegarse unos a otros.
Pero...esperad un momento, porque no, no es eso lo
que Donald Trump tenía dentro de su
cabeza.
Por supuesto, no tardó ni 24 horas en
dejar clara su postura. En su primera
entrevista a la mañana siguiente, en el
programa "Morning Joe" de la MNSBC Trump
soltó esta perla:
- "El presidente electo de Estados Unidos
ha dicho que hay que dejar que haya una
carrera armamentística en una
declaración telefónica fuera de antena
al programa "Morning Joe" de la cadena MNSBC.
Sí, así es, lo que Donald Trump estaba
anunciando era, ni más ni menos,
su intención de desencadenar una guerra
armamentista y todo con un tweet.
Apuesto a que en ese momento tanto sus
asesores como la gente del Pentágono y
de la Secretaria de Estado se llevaron
las manos a la cabeza.
Ahora comprenderéis porque en la
campaña le quitaron el Twitter. Y ante
semejante declaración de intenciones la
pregunta no puede ser otra: ¿tiene sentido
esta afirmación? ¿Es una apuesta vital y
necesaria?
¿O es que acaso como buen populista Trump
sólo busca reavivar un temor social
para poder aprovecharse de él?
Bueno, vamos a verlo.
Estos son los nueve países que a día
de hoy se conoce que tienen armas
nucleares: Estados Unidos, Rusia, China,
Francia, Reino Unido, la India, Pakistán,
Israel y el recién llegado al club, Corea del Norte.
Claro que, no todos tienen los mismos
arsenales y las mismas capacidades.
Tan sólo Rusia y Estados Unidos
acaparan la inmensa mayor parte de las
ojivas nucleares:
nueve de cada diez bombas pertenecen a
esos dos países.
Y os preguntaréis ¿cuál es la amenaza
real para Estados Unidos? Caso a caso:
Primero, Reino Unido, Francia e Israel no
suponen riesgo alguno, son países amigos.
Segundo, la India y Pakistán no tienen
capacidad de atacar a los Estados Unidos.
De hecho, su mayor riesgo, especialmente
en el caso de Pakistán, es que algún
grupo terrorista se hiciese con el
control de alguna ojiva o de material
para fabricar bombas sucias para emplear
en atentados. Y desde luego este recibo
no se combate con más misiles
balísticos.
En tercer lugar, Corea del Norte. Se calcula que tiene
menos de diez bombas desarrolladas y se
duda si quiera que sea capaz de lanzar
alguna en un misil intercontinental.
Aun así, si las capacidades son tan
diferentes que en caso de que este país
pudiera y quisiera  utilizar su
rudimentario arsenal, Estados Unidos
podría destruirlo
en cuestión de minutos.
En cuarto lugar, China el gran enemigo de Trump.
China, china, china...
Bueno, pues a pesar de todo lo que este
país se está gastando, se calcula que
podrían llegar a contar con cien
cabezas nucleares en misiles balísticos
intercontinentales dentro de diez años.
Un número que, en ningún caso, les
permitiría impedir la represalia de las
casi 1.500 cabezas nucleares que Estados
Unidos podría utilizar en apenas unas
horas.
Y por último, Rusia el gran rival de
Estados Unidos en el terreno nuclear.
En este caso la destrucción mutua está
asegurada y más ojivas no cambiarían para
nada el escenario.
Además, pese a que muchos de los que nos
veis nunca nos lo reconoceréis, no
conviene olvidar la enorme superioridad
que EEUU tiene en la guerra convencional:
desde la marina hasta la fuerza aérea,
pasando por la capacidad de desembarco,
los ataques de precisión y por supuesto
la pasta. Las Fuerzas Armadas
estadounidenses son con diferencia las
más poderosas del planeta, a mucha
distancia de sus adversarios.
Sólo Estados Unidos concentra un tercio
de todo el gasto militar del mundo,
y otro tercio lo hacen países  que son aliados
y socios.
A finales de la década de los 60
quedó clara la capacidad de destrucción
mutua entre Estados Unidos y la Unión
Soviética y la imposibilidad, así, de ganar
una guerra nuclear
en aquel momento. La potencia
norteamericana como vaís a ver en el
siguiente gráfico comenzó a reducir
los arsenales y trató de llegar
a acuerdos con la Unión Soviética para
limitar el número de cabezas nucleares
listas para el ataque.
Esta estrategia ha reducido en un 80 por
ciento el número de armas nucleares
desplegadas desde 1989.
Precisamente, el último acuerdo conocido
como Start III lo firmó Obama hace relativamente
poco, en 2010. El acuerdo limita a
1.550 las cabezas nucleares que ambos
países pueden tener desplegadas y
limita también los sistemas de
lanzamiento en submarinos, bombarderos o
misiles intercontinentales. Es decir,
incrementar el arsenal nuclear como
defiende Trump, supondría romper, ni más ni
menos, uno de los acuerdos más
importantes de la historia de la
humanidad
¡y todo por twitter!
El resultado sería que Estados Unidos y Rusia acumularían
más cabezas nucleares
sin ganar nada de seguridad. Vamos, como
diría Fonseca,
¡menuda ideaca! Es tan absurdo que, en
2013, el Pentágono concluyó que Estados
Unidos podría tener un tercio menos de
armas nucleares que Rusia sin que se
viese afecta la seguridad nacional, pero
Trump quiere más. Y aquí no acaba la
cosa.
Una de las críticas más recurrentes
de Trump es que las capacidades nucleares
están viejas y obsoletas, por ello no se
cansa de decir que hay que lanzar un
mega plan para modernizarlas y poner
nuevos sistemas sobre la mesa.
Solo hay un problema, amigos de VisualPolitik:
Obama ya lo ha hecho.
Sí, la administración Obama ha concedido
contratos para desarrollar nuevos
bombarderos, submarinos, misiles y ojivas
con los que modernizar el equipamiento
de Estados Unidos, y mejorar así su
capacidad de ataque nuclear por tierra,
mar y aire, lo que se conoce como la
triada nuclear.
El presupuesto es, ojo, descomunal: más de
800.000 millones de dólares en las
próximas décadas, de los cuales 350.000
se habrán gastado ya dentro de ocho
años.
De hecho, hace muy poco el Pentágono
presentó, por ejemplo ,el nuevo súper
bombardeo nuclear B21 Ryder, que será
tremendamente sigiloso y.... caro. Cada
unidad costará 550 millones, sin contar
el presupuesto desarrollo.
La pregunta que muchos hacen hoy en
Washington es si Estados Unidos debe
hacer frente a semejante gasto. Puede que
por todo esto
James Mattis, alias perro loco, el general
retirado que Trump  ha escogido como
Secretario de Defensa, defienda incluso
que el programa nuclear tenga que
reducirse.
Es llamativo que en algo tan importante
como la estrategia nuclear, Trump tenga  tan
poco en cuenta a la persona que ha
escogido para dirigir a las fuerzas
armadas.
Y es que parece de cajón pensar que la
política de defensa,
amigos, no puede conducirse por twitter.
Bueno y tú ¿qué piensas? ¿Debe Estados
Unidos romper con la política de los
últimos 30 años y lanzarse a una
carrera armamentística? ¿Contradice todo
esto los mensajes de Trump en campaña?
Por cierto, si quieres conocer la
controvertida apuesta comercial de Trump
puedes ver este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima